I invited some friends to play games in a pub.
No big prizes, just bragging rights
and the end card of the video.
Joining me this time are
Sophie Ward from science channel Soph's Notes,
musician dodie,
stand-up mathematician Matt Parker,
and a charging cable that got caught
in the 360 camera shot,
and which we're just gonna
have to deal with.
Sophie, dodie, Matt,
thank you very much for
joining me in the pub.
The game is No Thanks!,
and here's how it's played.
There's a deck of cards with
every number between 3 and 35.
But for each game, nine of those cards
have been removed from the deck at random.
In each round, a card is turned over,
and each player in turn can either
place a token on it
and pass it on to the next player,
or take the card
and all the tokens on it.
If you have no tokens left,
you must take the card.
Once all the cards have been taken,
the game ends.
Each player's score is the sum of
the numbers on their cards,
less one point for each token they have,
and the lowest score wins.
So cards are bad and tokens are good,
but they're not gonna be able to pass on every card.
And there is one other rule:
If they've got a stack of consecutive cards,
only the lowest of that stack counts.
Right! I mean, who's starting...?
Cool, I'll start!
Oh wait, should we hide our counters?
Yes, hide your counters.
I have to give it a...
This wasn't even the highest yet.
Oh, that's true. You have eleven,
we all have eleven count.
Everyone can count.
Oh, do you(?)
Huh. Um...
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Alright, well...
I mean, I'm just gonna take the 3.
I'm just gonna have that.
What's your advantage of taking that?
If I take— If I put a counter on that...
Yeah?
...you can take it and get
a grand total of two points.
Ah, so you were just stopping me...
I'm stopping you going,
"I'll have that and the counter."
You'd rather take a 3...
I'd rather take a hit of three points...
...than give me a 2.
...than give you—
I'd rather take the hit of three than
you take two points and get one of my counters.
That's a big deal.
Okay, okay.
It literally says on the card,
"Great! I'm the best! Pick me, take me!"
18, that can go around the table.
You have no interest in 18?
We'll see how many...
Okay, okay. Interesting.
There is an advantage to having
some high cards in front of you,
because then other cards get cheaper
if the next one comes up.
So... alright.
Okay, yeah.
That's a lot of chocolate buttons!
I'll send it around one more.
Or...
I probably shouldn't say
my strategy out loud.
Oh no, please Tom.
What we could do is add a token,
and then we could slide it on.
I thought we were gonna physically slide it.
And then you can say thanks or no thanks.
Yeah.
Delicious. Yum-yum-yum.
I'm gonna take it.
So it's a hit of 12 points in total,
but you've now got a load of counters
that you can throw away other cards with.
So you pick the next card.
Wow.
Second highest card in the game.
Pretty big. I'm gonna put
a wee counter on that.
Yeah, I think I understand the game enough
to know I should put a counter down on that.
Yeah, that's going round.
No thanks(!)
You don't have to say it. The rules say...
But I can!
There's no rule that says you're
not allowed to say it every time.
Okay...
I don't have a good gauge of...
Surely like half, right?
I don't know, 'cause...
'Cause the advantage of taking that
is if 33 or 35 come up,
you are in such a strong position.
Ooh, right, yeah.
Yeah, 'cause then you got loads of...
Right, yeah.
Yeah, I'm taking it.
Alright.
Thanks!
Wow!
Ooh, okay.
I was going to, if he didn't, so...
Yeah, well— Okay, okay.
'Cause now I'm starting to get
a little bit antsy
about how many counters I've got.
My hand's a bit light, isn't it? It's a bit light.
It literally says "I'm a loser" on it.
Yes, it does.
A little passive-aggressive
for a play piece in the game.
Being heckled by the—
Oh no!
Oh, no!
What?!
35...
Those cards were thoroughly shuffled.
...how I love you.
You know, if you love something,
you set it free.
So I'm gonna...
No, you're not!
Go explore the world.
Come back to me...
'Cause you know you're never gonna get the 34.
...when you're ready to settle down.
Well, I don't want it!
"Oh, no!"
Am I gonna be a martyr?
Am I gonna screw over your game?
But at what cost?
At what cost?
You know what? I'm gonna take it.
I'm gonna do that for the team.
Alright, your call.
There you are.
Yeah, my call.
But I'm not at a loss,
other than I would've got some tokens.
And then it would've vanished
beneath my 34. Gotcha.
I got greedy,
is what I'm trying to say.
Eh...
I'm getting really thrown
by my rash decision.
"Double that." I just like reading
all the little things they say on the cards.
"Still a great value!
Eleven is heaven!"
"Eleven is heaven," sure.
There we go.
If it helps your previous decision,
I am really disappointed,
'cause getting sequential numbers
would've pleased me.
Yeah, yeah.
So now I regret
even sending it around.
I just wanna show that you can't just
send something around and expect to get it back.
Everyone's gonna play by my expectations.
The boomerang does not always spin around, Matt.
If there were a couple more
in there, I'd take it.
But I'm gonna send that a bit further.
The only thing I love more than
sequential numbers is palindromes.
Oh god damn it, Matt!
So... I'll take that.
Add these to the bank.
I don't know how many—
A sting of regret, even though
you made the wrong decision.
Yeah. Alright, your card.
Key to the door.
Oh no, it's not. It's not bingo, is it?
There are little number facts on these.
"Drop it like it's hot," it says.
"Double down."
I'm in the majority.
This is a missed opportunity,
'cause they could have facts about the number.
And they've got words
that rhyme with the number.
Do you have any facts
about that number?
A palindromic prime.
I really need some counters.
And if I don't take this—
What, the six you're holding aren't enough?
21 is quite big, though.
God damn it!
Ohh, Matt again!
We're playing with the wrong person here.
I know!
Counter-counting. That's why they call them
'counters', Tom. You count them.
I'm gonna have to take this.
I'm gonna have to.
Wow.
I really don't want that, but—
I underestimated
the force we were playing with(!)
Nine will keep me going for a while.
If I didn't take that, dodie was gonna take it,
and the hope I think of 19 and 20.
So let's see.
Oh god, right, yeah, no.
I'm gonna pass that.
28 can go on.
28? Ohh, that's a perfect number.
How are you playing this game?
Why am I playing a numbers game
with Matt Parker(?)
I've gotta have that. That's really nice.
On only one?
You could've sent that 'round.
Nah, I've learnt that lesson.
It's too late. It's too late now.
I'd be the owner of a 35 if that were true.
I've scared him. He's shook now.
Why did you take that?
I don't know why he took that.
If you add together all the numbers...
that divide into 28,
apart from 28,
they add together
to give you 28.
That's— That's the definition
of a perfect number.
That is not an answer to the question,
"Why did you take that?"
I think it answers both those questions(!)
'Cause there's no 496
in the deck, Tom. That's why.
That's the next number up.
"I'm leaving!"
Sorry!
"Now what is going on here?"
9.
Ooh, thank you.
Nah.
I really thought you were
gonna be like...
It's not an interesting number.
"I like nine."
I'm gonna take it.
Ah, I've would've done—
I would've taken that.
Yeah, you would've, three counters!
Yeah, you need those counters.
Yeah. Uh, your card.
How many counters does Matt have?
Nine.
Nice, good to know.
We've got a 16 in the house, everyone.
And thing is, he's wrong.
That was confident, but he's wrong.
Oh really?
Yes.
You're down to eight.
Thank you for correcting, I woulda...
Yeah, why'd I do that?
It would've been off by one.
I'm not counting anyone else's,
including my own, by the way.
I only know...
I regret being the host of this!
...only know Tom's.
I just realized as well that
as I keep taking cards,
I can also stop you from getting counters.
Yeah. I think dodie's gonna take this...
because there's 17, and I...
But I don't want just one counter from it.
I'll pass that on.
Hmm...
You've got loads of numbers.
I have got loads of numbers.
Acquiring the best numbers is
not technically the point of this game.
16's a good number.
What?
You can write it as either 4² or 2⁴.
Oh, I love that. That's good.
And very few numbers you can do that.
In fact, I think it's the only number
that's non-trivial and you can do that.
So it would go well in my collection.
Yeah, I'm having it. I'm having it.
I talked myself—
Stop asking me about the numbers!
What is happening?
I think this is a solid strategy
on dodie's part.
I'm not talking about any more numbers!
Just saying, "What do you like about that number?
"Tell me what you like about that number."
Have you ever heard of a game
called Wingspan?
Imagine this, but with birds.
And the objective...
...is to actually collect the best birds.
I've played that. I've played that.
Oh, for god's sake!
Oh, what?
I mean, it'll go well with my 10.
You know what you missed here?
Ohhh!
You know what you missed?
Yeah.
That 9. You missed that 9.
Ohh!
Yeah!
Oh, my— Oh!
Wow!
Wait, so it's the lower number...
Lower number goes on top.
See, because you all wrote me off.
I was still riding high from the 16,
and I dropped the ball.
"Nine is fine." Exactly, card.
Your card.
Thank you very much.
And it's a 20.
Oh, hello!
Ooh.
So you...
Everybody!
oooo!
oooO!
ooOO!
oOOO!
OOOo!
OOoo!
Oooo!
oooo!
Yeah, you need counters.
If you— He will definitely take that.
I don't know, will he though,
because he really needs counters.
One counter for 20?
If he passes it around.
Uh, Matt.
Oh, oh yeah. He'll pocket your counter.
What do you think we— I don't know.
This isn't a team strategy game.
No, apparently it is now(!)
It is now. Can we just have a side huddle(?)
I'm also gonna point out...
I'm also gonna point out that
dodie's gonna take it.
In case of— 19 might be taken out there...
I know dodie will.
So if I don't take it—
I don't know why.
I know you've invited us all here today,
but I just feel a need to, like,
mess things up for you, Mr. Scott.
I mean, I vote for you
messing things up for Tom.
Bear in mind...
This is a democracy(!)
...that if you mess it up for me here,
that puts you in a worse position.
I could win the game because of that.
Yeah, that is quite...
All you're doing is
shooting yourself in the foot.
He will take your counter and that card.
Yeah, maybe he needs a counter.
I'm sorry it's always up to you.
It's okay.
As you can tell,
I deal very well with pressure.
Okay, I'll pass it, I'll pass it.
Tasty, tasty card.
But you do need more counters, Tom.
Well, I am tempted to send it 'round.
You know now that I'm not gonna take it.
'Cause I don't think 20's an interesting number,
so he's not gonna take it.
It's boring. No, you're good.
I don't know. You can't trust him.
I think dodie's gonna take it, so I'm gonna
cut my losses and take that counter.
Ooh, I could've had
two extra chocolate buttons.
They're like Minstrels.
Do you remember Galaxy Minstrels?
13... ooh.
Not anyone here.
That can go 'round.
That's my lucky number
though, thirteen.
So there's what, a...
About a one-in-three chance, roughly.
Oh, the card counting, yeah.
I forgot that was an aspect of the game.
I can't just keep taking
all the fun little cards. I can't.
I got sad that I didn't have a lot of cards,
and then I realized that was a good thing.
I know.
Um...
You still have counters somehow.
I...
It is quite a low number.
...might take it.
That's not an unreasonable call there.
♪ I'm gonna do it ♪
Alright, your card.
Oh, very exciting.
Ooh.
It's a 25.
No one has anything near it.
Yeah, I would not like that.
Yeah, I also do not.
That is definitely going around.
Oh my goodness.
♪ Round round, round round ♪
But would I put it
in the square number pile...
...or would I—
I'm gonna send that 'round.
Oh man. Oh, tasty,
tasty chocolate buttons.
Looking... oh, that looks pretty full!
I really don't want this.
Oh, but you really need counters, Tom.
I don't really need counters.
I think you're convincing yourself
that you don't need counters.
No, I don't.
I'm still good for counters.
Kinda reminds me of, like, Monopoly.
Do you know what I mean?
Of what?
Like you're waiting for the...
Oh, Monopoly.
Yeah, it's like...
I thought you said, "Not play."
On it goes.
I was like,
"How'd you not play before?"
Gnocchi(!)
"Gnocchi."
That's a lot of black things.
But that is a very big number.
And I can't add up quickly
how much this means.
So....
I'm gonna take it.
So how many...
you're gaining, like, eight of those.
So, your next card.
Oh yeah.
Ooh.
29.
Oh, oh.
Ohh!
Okay— Oh, it's you.
I... don't want it.
I'm not gonna take it again, so...
I...
So 30 hasn't come up yet.
30 has not come up yet, no.
Nor has 31, which would be
the matching prime for that one.
And if I take this, he can't have it.
I've lost track of how many counters
he's got as well.
Oh.
Are you gonna use
one of your five on passing it on?
You are.
How?! How?!
I'll take those!
Oh my gosh.
'Cause it only changes one at a time, Tom.
It's easy to keep track.
That is amazing.
Wow.
I just feel there's so many other things
to be thinking about.
I don't wanna give any brain cells
to Tom's counters.
But I dedicated one thing under my brain!
Just to irritate me!
I knew it would bug you.
I knew it would really bug you.
Pick a damn card!
I might join in that.
Do it! It's good fun.
Oh, oh.
Oh, oh!
Whatever happens, I'm not in this game(!)
Still got a third— There's no chance(!)
I've got no chance.
You may as well... help a lass out.
Now, you wouldn't let us...
pay each other off with counters.
No. No promises
outside the game, Matt.
But I can just innocently
send this one around the table.
Mhm.
Just like that.
Oh, I feel like
I'm giving you a present.
Well, thank you so—
Aww, thank you very much!
I'm enjoying this game.
I don't like this number.
It's that awkward point where
you don't know whether you should say...
You don't look like
you're reassured at all.
Are we ready to see the next card?
Yeah.
It's a 26!
Oh, that shade of 25
is gonna change around!
"Awful, dreadful," it says.
If a 27 comes up, that puts him
in such a powerful position.
But also, there's no counters on this.
'Cause I haven't got a stack yet.
You've only got three
once you've put one on there, Tom.
See? Now it's a team sport!
Isn't it fun?
It's so much.
Counting counters is fun. We've been through this.
Three isn't that many, is it?
Bless your soul.
Nah, if I took this,
and the 27 shows up...
You are in a very powerful position.
I know, but the odds of me getting it are slim.
That's true.
It would have to land in front of me.
Yeah, it is very slim.
Especially because if you don't—
And if I pass this on...
It's more likely—
See, the thing about 26—
If you pass it on,
there's gonna be a fight for the 27.
Well, the fun fact about 26...
Here we go.
It's the only number between
a square number and a cube number.
You could have deduced that
from my previous fun fact!
So, there we are.
I think it belongs in a winning set.
Yay!
Yeah.
I mean, I was gonna say, "Was she gonna
send it 'round for one more lap?"
But you would totally take that.
Yeah, that was already risky.
Yeah, you can't be pushing it.
Your card. If this is the 27,
I'm gonna laugh my arse off.
Ooh, 12!
Oh! We got a fight. Okay!
Fight, fight, fight.
Might take this just to be a dick.
Don't do that!
You flipped that.
Oh yeah. Oh my gosh.
I could take it.
Yeah, you could just pocket it.
I got overexcited, my bad.
What are the benefits of taking it?
He doesn't get it.
And you don't have to...
And you actually lose a point.
You're right.
Alright, your card.
Here we go again.
15. You got 16, Matt.
Okay, okay.
Alright, alright.
But also, if the 14 is left
in that pile, dodie...
I know, I'm so excited.
Oh, that would be so good!
14 hasn't come up yet, has it?
There's no way that's gonna
get past Tom to me.
I've passed it on. Go for it.
Yeah, there you go.
Yeah, I'm not giving you two counters
and mine at this point.
That's not going past me. Right.
17? Oh, for god's sake!
I can't just take a 17 card hit,
'cause I know the 15—
I've got to pass that on.
I've got to.
I've got to take that.
I'm sorry.
There's no other move there.
I feel like— I feel like—
I passed the 25,
I'm gonna keep the 17.
'Cause it's a free token.
You're so kind.
Your card.
Okay, here we go.
32— oh.
That's very big.
No one wants that.
That's lovely.
Yeah, then I can fill this.
Yeah.
But I'm taking it out of nowhere.
No one else wants it.
No one else wants the card with the highest power
in its prime decomposition in the deck!
So... I'm gonna...
set it sail.
I do this thing you do with numbers,
but I do it so much more simple.
I'm like, "Oh, I like that
three is one more than two(!)"
It's exactly the same thing(!)
I get the feeling that both dodie and I
are very much out of our depth here.
Oh yeah. Big time.
Especially now you've
only got four counters left.
Wrong!
No!
No, he's on three.
I'll take those.
I got cocky over that.
That's why we've got buddies
keeping track of it.
I appreciate the buddy system
of winding Tom up.
I'm not involved in that at all.
Oh! That's not too bad, is it?
Oh, cute.
"Cute!"
Very cute, little 4.
So I would only take this
to stop other people from...
Other people being...
Me.
You. Someone else is gonna...
For all the—
Exact— I know!
There are a lot of
very high numbers there.
Unless you make your hands lay,
you've got, like, 50 cards!
Unless you pull the 33...
I'm hoping.
Yeah.
And if you don't take that,
Tom definitely will.
Yeah no, I want that.
Give that a home.
Sorry, that was quite a threat, wasn't it?
"If you don't take this...
...then I'm gonna sort you out!"
It's 23.
Ooh.
We don't have any...
There you go.
See, I am tempted by this,
'cause no one else has got...
If I don't take this, dodie will,
I think, in the hope of a 24.
I'm going to hope— How many cards?
There's only two cards left.
If either—
If 22 comes up, I'm—
So also, with only two cards left,
how many counters do I need?
I'm going to take this
on the gamble...
on the gamble that this...
Nah, there's no way.
We shuffled these thoroughly!
We shuffled these so thoroughly!
What is wrong with you?
You know what? You know what?
That's some kind of cosmic joke.
It's going 'round!
No!
Oh man!
Tom, what on earth?!
Oh my days!
Still no guarantee I'm gonna win this.
Are you thinking about it?
Nah, I'm sending it on.
Ah, yeah.
You can have the tokens.
There's only three.
I think you're in deep, mate.
I feel like...
Is that enough?
Enough of a treat that...
I don't— So, I—
I did a bit of my little maths there.
You're not in a good place.
It's going around again.
He's doing it again!
There it is. He's playing with fire.
It's greedy, but...
He can only do this one more time.
Because I know I've got
both sides of it. That's the thing.
No one else wants those—
With only one card left.
How well would you do?
And it collapses down.
You would do so well.
It just concertinas the whole thing down.
Yeah, it does.
What happens if I took this?
Would it be really bad?
It wouldn't be... great.
It wouldn't be... the worst.
That sounds like
something you'd say.
Oh, okay, fine.
I'm taking it. Oh my days.
Oh, yeah! Solid move.
Just to cause—
So you're costing yourself 15 points—
You don't know how many tokens
I've got in my little paw.
Your paw? Alright.
Alright, finally.
It's a 5. She's taking it.
There it is. It ends so quickly.
Alright.
There is now the awkward bit where—
we will get cut out—
where we all total up our points.
I'm getting the calculator for this.
You guys can help me.
So I have 59.
Uh, 106.
What? No!
These are...
Yeah, well that's 66 there alone.
Yeah?
That's another...
That's now 94.
Yeah, okay.
And then, that's fifteen,
so that's one.
Yep.
Right.
So that's another twelve,
and 106.
106, 59...
Yeah, I shouldn't have been—
You shouldn't have been.
This is very embarrassing.
What's 45 minus... is this 14?
I think.
Yeah. Yeah, that's 14.
Wait, do you only have...?
Wow!
Yeah.
Yeah, we got a sleeper.
55 minus 14, right?
45, right? Is it fifty—
40. 55, minus 14.
55.
So you're on 41, which beats my—
Solid.
I'm 56, I think.
dodie's taken it.
The underdog!
dodie's taken it!
Well done, well done!
Yes!
We're here counting Tom's counters.
You know that move there?
That cost both of us the game.
Worth it! Worth it!
Wow!
If I'm going down, Tom,
you're going down with me(!)
dodie, 20 seconds to the camera!
What are you doing?
I have an album out.
It's called Build a Problem.
You should listen to it.
It's really good.
And I'm going on tour.
Okay, cool.
There we go!
Sophie, dodie, Matt,
thank you so much!
We get to keep these now?
No.
[Caption+ by JS*
https://caption.plus]